And Ukraine's capital, where
the mayor of Kiev
is vowing to make sure
bomb shelters are open at night
for those who need them.
That's after three people died
during a Russian
missile attack overnight
when they could not
get into a locked shelter.
Ukraine's military said it shot down
all ten missiles fired at Kiev.
And that latest round of strikes.
But falling debris killed three victims,
including a nine year old girl
and her mother.
I want to bring in
senior international correspondent
Sam Kiley,
who is in eastern Ukraine for us.
Tragically, Sam, tragically,
the inability to enter
a shelter
caused the death of 33 people,
including a little girl.
How did this happen?
Well, again,
it is a kind of extraordinary event
because
the citizens of Kiev have got so used
to coming under air attack
that one of the problems
for the local administration
is to get people
to go
into those bomb shelters
or to take shelter
in metro stations
or the centers of their homes.
People just ignore the sirens
or very often ignore the sirens.
But on this occasion,
it would appear that
a significant number
of civilians gathered
at the doors
of this bomb shelter in Kiev,
banged on the doors, thought
that they may be in other points of entry
because they couldn't
believe
that it was not possible
to get into a bomb shelter.
And then, tragically,
a missile was destroyed in the sky
above them.
The descending debris killed
three people and injured others.
An extraordinary
series of catastrophic moments
of bad luck.
Arguably, perhaps nobody would have been
at that bomb shelter been opened.
Now, that is, of course,
part of now an official investigation
by the Ukrainian authorities.
These are bomb shelters
that have been around,
in fact, were built
during the Cold War
as a defensive measure against
NATO's attack.
And ironically, of course,
it is Russia
that is attacking
Ukraine at a time
when Ukraine is discussing joining Naito
as a consequence of the Russian invasion.
Well, any
yeah.
I mean, it is an absolutely tragic story
because Ukraine said
that it intercepted all ten missiles.
But look, we've also seen,
as you say,
an increase
in the number of attacks
inside of Russia.
What more do we know about the group
behind the attacks?
And I guess the question is,
are we looking at the beginning
of the counter offensive
Well, the new phase,
what is absolutely no doubt
is that what we haven't seen before
is outright attacks
on Ukrainian territory.
Coming from Ukrainian territory.
So about a week ago, we saw Russians
who are dissident Russians, part
of the Ukrainian
forces, crossing into Russian territory,
ostensibly under their own steam,
but take that
with a pinch of salt
and conducting
military operations inside
Russia, that the Ukrainian intelligence
said were very valuable.
They went about eight kilometers,
five miles inside the territory.
Now, those two self,
same groups claim
that they have crossed the borders.
Again, the Russians are claiming
they have repelled them.
We don't have any independent
corroboration yet one way or the other.
But a lot of this is concurrent now
with ongoing shelling of Russian villages
from Ukrainian territory
attributed obviously by the Russians
to the Ukrainians, causing
eight injuries,
according to the governor
of Belgorod Province.
And the force, well, the necessity
to evacuate civilians
from a number of border
villages inside Ukraine.
Now, of course,
the Ukrainians have signaled adviser
to the president saying yesterday
that we could expect
to see more of these kind of operations
and indeed,
the quote unquote,
mysterious drone strikes
that have hit Moscow
and Krasnodar oil refineries.
This is the new phase
in the war
that the Ukrainians are prosecuting,
there's no doubt about that.
All right.
Sam Kiley, thank you so much.
Well, as the war in Ukraine continues,
so too are its efforts to join Naito.
The head of the bloc is underlining
Ukraine's part in NATO's future
as he meets
with foreign ministers in Oslo.
At least one member
needs some more
convincing as the German foreign
minister signals skepticism.
That Ukraine
should be allowed to join the bloc
while at war.
Ukrainian President Volodymyr Zelensky,
joining a summit in Moldova,
says the time is now.
Ukraine is ready to be in need.
We are waiting
when NATO's will be ready to host
and we stand to have Ukraine
and I think security
guarantees are very important,
not only for Ukraine,
for all the neighbors, for Moldova,
because of of the Russia
and of their aggression
in Ukraine and potential aggression for
that part of Europe.
Sebastian is following
all these developments
for us from London.
Great to have you on.
Look, Germany,
as we've heard, very hesitant
to allow a country currently
in a war to join NATO.
That's the reality.
It's interesting that Jens
Stoltenberg says that Ukraine will be
at some point joining Naito.
Well, we don't know
when what the timeline would be.
Yeah, this is about timing, Alina.
I think
in the NATO alliance as a whole,
probably a majority of countries would
would be in favor of Ukraine
eventually joining the alliance.
The operative word
being eventually it has been clear
and of course, made even clearer today
by the German foreign minister
and the secretary general himself.
But it's been clear
all along that they couldn't join
while at war with Russia.
Because, of course, of the way
that NATO's
structured, Article five
would mean that NATO allies
would have to come to Ukraine,
to Ukraine's defense,
and then we would, of course,
have the unthinkable.
The NATO alliance at war with Russia,
you know,
so we even just have some holdouts here.
The Ukrainian foreign minister,
according to his spokesperson,
is saying that NATO's that Ukraine's
accession to NATO
shouldn't even be discussed
at the summit in Vilnius.
They have been more opposed than others.
But overall,
I think the alliance is looking at this
in the long term.
The frustration
for Ukraine
is, of course, that that really
has been the situation for 15 years.
Secretary Blinken saying today
we stand by the Bucharest commitment
that was made in 2008 to support
Ukraine's eventual accession to NATO.
So he really wants
some kind of interim step
to bring home
to his people security guarantees.
You heard him say an invitation
to clear invitation
from NATO and the same from the E.U.
He wants a sort of clear
path to membership
there, essentially saying, look,
we are paying with our blood
for European values, for freedom
in Ukraine.
If we can't get these concrete decisions,
then what hope for other countries
Sebastian, thank you so much.
Great to see you.